and they'll also talk about verification
or magnitudes for me it's a great
pleasure to be here to talk about our
research on proving differential privacy
we're on relational types my background
is also in programming languages so this
is about formal methods this is based on
joint working with my colleague Dan
Kieffer at Penn State and our students
and so you home and using this project
is supported by ICF so in this workshop
I believe I don't need to convince you
that the differential privacy it's a
very useful and the rigorous tool for
protecting data privacy because of the
popularity of differential privacy so we
have seen a lot of tools created just to
make it easier to develop software which
guarantees differential privacy that day
for the great introduction for pink so
that's one of these kind of tools all of
these tools are a little bit different
in their implementation and the designs
you can think they work roughly in the
same way so first they either analyze
the sensitivity of the queries like in
the fast or default system or require
the programmer to annotate what is the
sensitivity of those inputs none of
these tools use instead of verify the
basic differential privacy makanda done
such as the Laplace mechanism for
differential privacy right so if I know
the data is one sensitive then I can
apply apply some lap last noise to it to
make sure the readout is differentially
private then all of these tools rely on
a very important theorem in many
definitions of differential privacy
called the composition theorem so that
just means if each query carries a cost
of on Q then total cost for the entire
software with kake queries will be K
times the cost of each query so this is
pretty fundamental in all these tools
making these tools pretty useful but
also limits its usefulness
so to make that clear let me consider
one question that we want to answer so
the question is among a lot of one
sensitive numerical queries I want to
learn how many of them are above a
threshold say T so if we use these kind
of tools to develop our withum i bet to
the best route whether you can develop
and buy those tools is this one the
naive algorithm which apply the lifeless
mikedolan to each query and each query
you will pay the cost of Epsilon and at
the end you get a privacy cost of K
epsilon due to the concision theory so
these tools are pretty useful if we only
want to implement these native evidence
but in fact a lot of times in reality we
want most sophisticated evidence which
actually requires more advanced the
proofs instead of the proofs you can't
derive from the concision theory so my
example I have is the space vector
technique so it runs to exactly the same
question how many queries are above a
threshold T but this clever method
actually answer the same question in a
more accurate way I will show you the
color of SVG shortly but intuitively
they are with an only pay cost for the
queries that are above the threshold
making it more precise than the previous
algorithm where each query carries some
privacy cost the fact thing is that you
can't use the previous tools to show
that to this everything is actually
epsilon private so if we use the
previous tools you will you can only
show its k-epsilon private instead of
epsilon private so there's a missing gap
and moreover what it make more sorrow is
that we have the correct version of SVT
and we have actually a lot of variants
which T tweak the original algorithm a
little bit there are papers published
about those variants of the SVT with
some paper based the proofs
in fact research has found that some of
the proofs and the some of the evidence
are actually incorrect even though they
are peer-reviewed okay so the takeaway
message here is that for those very
important building blocks of
differential privacy or you think those
differentially private course for
orbitons call mechanisms in the
differential privacy system a lot of
them are very subtle to proof and like
the SVT are whether even if you change a
small part of a logarithm you believe
your tweak is still correct
well actually the paper breeze to prove
its not trustful so a lot of times
people just make make mistakes in those
paper based of rules so we want formal
methods okay so in programming languages
community we have studied formal methods
for decades and this talk is about how
we can apply some formal methods to
mechanically check that the some of the
evidence are actually correct provably
correct in particularly in this talk i
will talk about two programming models
namely the light EP and the shadowed EP
so there are two programming languages
for designing and verifying the
correctness of differentially private
orbitons
when we design these two these
programming models they're kind of four
goals in in the design the first and the
most important goal as the most formal
methods we want guarantee soundness
meaning that a verify the program
probably satisfies differential privacy
so if I verify the program there's no
way that the program can't go wrong the
second goal here is to make it
expressive so we want to the
verification mechanism to verify as many
sophisticated evidence as possible
including the SVT technique we also want
this verification mackanin to be useful
it's it's a little bit challenging
because at the end of the day this tool
should be used by some someone who
design differentially private evidence
who are not necessarily
expert in formal methods so we want to
reduce the overhead reduce the
annotation burden and this learning
curve for the for the two as much as
possible and finally we want to make the
tool extensible by using those
off-the-shelf program verification tools
instead of reinventing those tools for
scratch so here is a very high-level
overview of our programming model how we
can make that happen so when you design
and verify evidence in so this is a
light DP example in lightly P this is
how the verification look like so my DP
have this program it's a programming
language which is very similar to the C
or Python language so we write to the so
here is the example of SVT so you write
to your algorithm in this language so
what happens here is first we draw Sun
Laplace noise with some scale factor and
add that to the threshold so we get
annoyed if threshold found out that he
for each query we also added a noise a
Laplace noise to the query and if the
noisy query is above the noisy threshold
we output a true otherwise we output
false and this orbital also limits how
many of our choose your output
eventually because each true output will
consume some privacy budget all this
wouldn't look very short as I argued
before it's actually very subtle to
prove its correctness and even if you
just change a very small part of the
source code you might get something that
is not differentially private so in
order to verify this source coding lie
DP so that's the orbital you write down
and the programmer also provide a few
annotations which right we are I will
talk about short me so with those the
verification can go automatically so
basically all the thing that the
programmer need to offer is these
annotations as well as what's the
implementation of the origin so with
that
we develop a type system will take
source code annotations and the check
your source told automatically if the
check path the type system will generate
something because the target program
which is very close to your original
program but it also have distinguished
the variable V Epsilon
so the importance here is this variable
here bounces the maximum budget cost so
the maximum amount of differential
privacy cost is founded by the value of
this VF now by some mcanally in the type
system which I will explain because of
this the target program can actually be
analyzed by some off-the-shelf verifiers
so that's something we have studied in
programming languages community for
decades how to verify that a variable is
always bounded by some constant epsilon
so we can use a listing tools to verify
that and the type system guarantees that
if both of the check paths that means
your source code is epsilon private so
that's a very high-level view of what's
going on here and let me go into some
details of how what's the magic in this
type system here so doing through out of
the talk I will assume the few
differential privacy or the epsilon
privacy how to extend our McCadden to
other definitions of differential
privacy that's still a future work so
impure differential privacy we have the
some database and adjacent database so
your program it's basically a algorithm
which runs on the database and it
generates some distribution because of
the noise injected to the data so
epsilon differential privacy just
specifies that for the final
distributions running on two different
databases that are at adjacent the
probability the ratio of the probability
of seeing the same value in two
distributions is bounded by e to the
power of alpha epsilon where epsilon is
a constant
so that's a pretty standard a definition
of epsilon privacy now let's see how we
can prove this kind of property in a
programming language so there are a lot
of techniques to prove differential
privacy and a lot of them can be
embedded into a programming language so
the technique we use is called
randomness alignment so the key idea
here is in order to prove differential
privacy I try to construct some
injective relation between the points on
two distributions so eventually I want
to show that these two distributions are
very close so I do that by create a
function injective function so if you
give me any point on the left the
function will give you a unique point on
the right so that we require to be
injective so to see why how that works
so let's consider a Laplace mackensen I
just draw a lot less noise and release
the Latinist noise so there's no secret
no private data so it shouldn't be it
should be zero private right so the way
to prove it is we created this function
here so I map all the three V on the
left to the same value on the right so I
add a zero just to make it more
generalized so we call the zero part of
the distance so this is just a special
case where the distance is zero and this
is a 10-8 function which is obviously
injective so based on this definition I
can show that for any value V the
probability of seeing V in the first
distribution is the same as the
probability of seeing the same value
beyond the second that is tuition in
other words this is zero differentially
private right so what make it more
interesting is if we add some private
data and they say Q and a Q by
definition differ by exactly 1 B 1 and D
2 so Q can be different so how can you
release some P which this depends on Q
society is that we can change the map a
little bit so instead of that I need
function we can map a V to the V + 1 to
the second distribution when you add
error to Q both differ by Y in the
opposite direction the difference will
cancel out so if we do the alignment in
this way so basically what we can show
is the probability of seeing V the ratio
or the privacy cost is bounded by 1 over
R because of the property of Laplace
noise and because of that we have
difference of 1 for error and difference
of Q by Y in the other direction so we
can actually show that to the value of P
will be identical so if you think about
what's the injective function on the
value of P so that will be an identity
function because it's identity function
and because of the relation here we can
prove that if I release the value of P
the it's 1 over R differentially private
let's give it give us idea of how the
key proof system in the in the language
works and one nice thing about this
proof system is that the proof is
basically here so that's how you align
the noise so the key of the proof is how
to create this injective function and we
can bear that into a programming
language in a pretty nice way so we can
embed that into a type so we lie DP or
type look like this so you have the B
which is a base type like the integers
boolean's doubles and so on so what's
new in our language is this B so the B
it's a numerical expression which
specifies the distance part of the
previous injective function or we call
it the alignment for the random noise
so for example if I write a type in this
way nam just means numeric type I've
specified a distance of a zero that just
means it has injective function which is
identity so I map anybody here to the
same value if I put a 1 for the distance
that I will not any value V to V plus 1
so what's powerful in this light DP
language is this D can't be some
arbitrary program expression in type
theory we call that a dependent type so
that really make it very expressive
we're powerful to verify the SVT so for
example I had these two types so I have
a distance 0 and the type of Y depends
on the value of x now if you think about
the Joint Distribution of X and y so if
I have a state where X is U and V Y is V
the related memory the related estate
will be X have the identical value here
and we Y will have V Plus u according to
your annotation there according to your
injective function so in more principle
if you think about a program a program
may have a lot of variables so in in the
end this gamma that types the type
environment or the types of the
variables create some relation between
two memories each memory have multiple
variables and two memories are related
if any variable is related by this gamma
and moreover we can live to this
definition to distributions of memories
and so that we can also relate to
distributions instead of two concrete
memories so that's the key insight
behind this on D the the key part of my
DP so that's annotation that to the
programmer needs to write down my TP
system will verify the program in a
pretty automatic way so let me try to
formalize what we can't guarantee by the
type system
so this is the standard way of
formalizing a probabilistic program so
you have arbitrary initial memory you
run a probabilistic program only the
initial memory what you get is a
distribution of possible final memories
differential privacy we care about two
executions of the probabilistic program
I have the original database here I have
the adjacent database here in in the
programming language word I call the
memory instead database I run the same
algorithm on a different set of data and
I get another distribution so
intuitively the goal is to prove that
these two distributions are very close
or it satisfies the differential privacy
definition if I use the camera the
injective function I just introduced
that actually can be specified in this
way so if I start from two memories
which are related by this injective
function so initially they are just this
adjacent database definition in other
words if I start from two other jason
databases if i execute any well type the
program it's guaranteed that the final
distributions are still related by this
scanner the types or the alignments in
the in the types with some privacy cost
which is bounded by this special
variable vietnam so this is at the high
level what are the type system
guarantees so for any well type the
program this relation holds if the
relation holds initially then the
relation holds on the final
distributions so now let me tell you a
little bit more on what it means to be
well typed in the light EP language so
this is how the types is thing in my DP
look like at the high level that type
system take your source code the
annotations
you check the source code so this
notation here means I check the original
command C under the type environment
gamma so I check it there are a couple
restrictions I which I will show you
next if the check path the type system
will generate a program C Prime
we call the target program so that's how
at a high level how the type system look
like and these are the restrictions on
to check in the type system if you see
the first time you see your type system
I guarantee this is the most the only
programming language intensive slider
out of the talk so you don't need to
understand in these annotations too much
so why is this is above the power those
are the restrictions or those other
checks the type system need to do so the
first check here is if this is
assignment I need to get the type of e
which contains the base type and the
difference the alignment alignments I
also can't get to the definition of X
which have this B and D so this is that
where the check happens so I make sure
that the towel agrees with the type of X
which makes sense because you want to
assign the value of e to X so it must be
true that the base type match as well as
the alignment also match so let make it
so this is where the check happens
what's more interesting is the second
rule here in the second row I have a lap
last noise on the left in the source
code according to the type annotation I
want to make it differ by the amount of
B so sign expression I want to noise in
two distributions to differ by the
amount of D so this is where you pay a
privacy cost because we have some
difference in the probabilities and by
the Laplace knows I know that the
difference is exactly bounded by this
the absolute value of D over R so this
is where we make the privacy caustics
place
in the transform the cold okay so
previously you need to reason about the
difference of two distributions the type
system make the difference very explicit
here so it's just the value of this
special variable V epsilon buy a cup of
guarantees of the type system and also
we transform away the probabilistic
program into a non-deterministic program
so so let me show you what is the
difference between a source language and
a target language so this is a soft
language where you have assignment
branch loop as and there is a special
command which is called a sampling
command so error is a sample energy is
some random distribution in the target
code the sampling code is replaced by
this have work instruction so
semantically the havoc just said to this
X to be our observe al you the very
important thing here is the source
language is probabilistic so it's a
distribution but the target language
because of the replacement we replace it
to our non-deterministic program so
there's no probability anymore there's
just it's only about possible values
that this X can take which actually
brings to a very favorable result so on
the target language there's nothing
special from the program verification
perspective so we have studied this
problem for decades so this is called a
safety property so we the task for the
target program is I want to verify the
special variable V epsilon is bounded by
some constant epsilon the desired
property the desired privacy bound in
any possible execution and because this
is not a probabilistic program it's
known as a safety property and we can
just reuse those of the shelf tools we
developed from the program verification
community like her logic model checking
tools to finish the final step to
check that to the VF snow in the target
language it's actually bounded by some
constant so so I have described of the
pieces of an IDP knowledge of the pieces
together and give you a more faithful
view of what happens in the in the
verification so first of the programmer
write down the source code in the lightt
P language it's just like a C code or
Python code so there's nothing special
here the programmer will need to write
down these types the type contains a
difference or the alignments I described
in the proof so each type have the
numerical part the base type part and
the distance part so this is only
annotation we require for the
programmers and a zero here just means
it's not private so in two other Jason
the database is the value of this
variable doesn't change and this thing
here is described the alignment on
strategy but I will not go into that but
and this is the most complex kind of
expressions you can distance you can
find in our proof so these annotations
they can either come from a programmer
or we also have a type C type inference
algorithm which can automatically infer
most of these types just to reduce
overhead furthermore so this is only
annotation required upon the programmer
from this step on everything is
automatic so the type system take the
annotation the source code it had
checked the source code according to the
restrictions described by the typing
rule and in this case it succeeds so we
will generate a target program in the
target program each left
Laplace mechanism is replaced by a
habakkuk instruction saying that this
this random sample can be arbitrary
value and we also add adjust to the
privacy cost according to your according
to the alignment so this is the target
program and the goal in the target
program is to prove that the V Epsilon
the special variable in the target
program is bounded by some constant
epsilon the main theorem of the type
system states that if the program type
checks and this target program in if
target program we absolutely pounded by
epsilon then your source program is
epsilon private and as I said before
this is just some pretty standard
program that we can use off the shelf
where fire to uncheck its correctness
so in our experiment we use the CPA
checker a model checker to verify this
code and this code can be verified
without any annotation from the
programmer so it's completely automatic
so let me quickly wrap up what we
developed in this light EP language by
looking at we're editing those goals I
set up in the initially so first we
proved our sound and experience saying
that any verified program probably
satisfies differential privacy
well expressiveness we verified those a
sparse vector technique and other
algorithms by Leidy P for usefulness the
programmer only needs to specify the
distances in those types so that small
DS in those types and furthermore most
of them can be automatically infrared by
the type system so there's really not
too much to work to do by the programmer
for extensibility we can reuse those of
the shelf program verification tools the
target program it's it can be readily
analyzed by those verification tools so
that's the light EP system which makes a
pretty good progress towards form of
verification of differential privacy
evidence and so that's the work in 2017
and we realized that is one limitation
however about our design so far so the
limitation is that we are not able to
verify the report noisy max or button
with a tight bond so you might ask why
this is important
so there are two reasons one is this
report annoys the max it's a pretty
useful building block of like the
exponential mechanism in differential
privacy and the second reason is that
there's another proof technique based on
programming languages and the coupling
based the proof which we were here in
the next talk I believe and that
technique can verify this report no is
Emacs so the question naturally is can
we use the same kind of argument to
prove this report in noisy Mac's so
that's something we have done recently
and the answer is of course yes so let
me first show you why we can't just
readily verify the not rapport no is
Emacs then I will show you the key idea
for the new technique we develop so this
is the report in noisy Mac's are rhythm
so the input is the list of query
answers with sensitivity of one the goal
is to output the index of the largest
query on sir
of course we want this to be
differentially private so the accuracy
is subject to some privacy constraints
so source code looks like this so I look
at each query in the query list and add
Laplace noise to each of them if it's
better than the answer the best query I
have seen so far them I update to the
maximum the index of the maximum query
and I also updates the best value I have
seen so far so it's looking a pretty
straightforward code but in terms of
verification there's actually some
challenges for this piece of code
so this let's reuse the alignment idea
that's a key idea behind on this kind of
proof so approve it's boys done to
create generate a alignment for the
noise in the in the system so this is
actually the best alignment we can get
in the 90 P system so the alignment
strategy is align the errors the random
noise by two by exactly - when a new max
is found
on the original database d1 so we look
at to the execution d1 and I try to
construct this alignment on the way so
this is the best strategy we can come up
with in the in the light DP system so
because of this strategy so when you see
the q1 which is the second query on d1
d1 and in this case we have a random
noise - so the new R and the new noisy
answer will be 4 which is greater than
the previous value you have seen so in
this case the max will be updated the
index of the maximum query will be
updated to 1 and in this case we will
align this error the noise in the second
execution by 2 by exactly 2 2 by doing
that we also pay a privacy cost of epson
so you might wonder why do I want to pay
a price the cost of Epsilon in that case
the reason is that if you do that it's
guaranteed that so the best query on d2
is always greater or equal than 1 plus
the best query on d1 because of the
sensitivity assumption so the
sensitivity is 1 and I add the noise on
the d2 by 2 so it's guaranteed that the
BQ r d2 is always greater than 1 plus
the Buchan t 1 so the consequence is
that if the one doesn't update to the
max if I reuse the same bit of noise
it's guaranteed that D - we are not
updated the max as well in other words
because of the way I do alignment if the
1 doesn't update to the max there's no
privacy cost so I will just to reuse the
same random bit from the first execution
or in other words the alignment is zero
and I don't pay any cost because I do
this alignment in this way so what make
it not precise is if I come up with a
new query answer where the one really
wants to update the query index so in
this case the noisy answer will be
five which is larger than the previous
query answer so I will update the index
to be three and in this case I also need
to align the arrow by two so this bit
will be one plus two three just to
guarantee that d2 will also update to
the index to be three but doing that now
the privacy cost is 2 Epsilon instead of
Epsilon
so even for this simple example by the
light DP based approve we can't show
that it's epsilon private we can only
show its to epsilon private instead of
epsilon private so the property it's not
the alignment technique is wrong it's
just it doesn't fit into this step
scenario it needs some change so to show
you what's the best alignment we can
come up with so this is a best alignment
strategy we can come up with so the
strategy is to just align error once and
only do that for the maximum query among
all of the queries so basically the
intuition is that you look ahead you
look at all the noisy answers on d1 and
the for the one that is the maximum you
change the noisy on the the noise to be
one plus two for all the rest of the
random bits you just to reuse the same
random value for the second first
execution it's guaranteed that to this
strategy will work out so it's
guaranteed that the final result of max
will be identical in the two runs but
there's something strange here something
strange is that you need to look ahead
you need to look at the future queries
as well as a future noise you get from
the Laplace in order to construct this
proof which is not very good so the
technique we propose a something called
shadow execution it's very simple here
so the idea here is we track two
executions on the other JSON database
one is called the line the execution why
it's called this shadow execution
so the shadow execution differ font
align the execution the way that in the
shadow execution we always use the same
random bit as the random bit you get
from the frost execution in other words
the alignment it's always zero for the
shadow execution the benefit is that
because the alignment is always zero we
never pay any cost if we use any value
computed from the shadow execution so
that actually allows us to construct a
proof so for the aligned execution it's
the same as strategy one I've aligned
error by two whenever I see a new max so
initially I see a new max so this
alignment will be 2 so 0 is aligned with
to intersect in a line execution what's
interesting is during the execution I
can actually switch between the aligned
version and the shadow version so one
way if you think about it is we actually
track another option for the proof
that's a shadow execution sometimes I
can switch my proof to the back hub
proof
so in this case if I see a new max in
the first on for the execution d1 I will
switch to the previous execution on the
shadow so the shadow values will be used
under the new random bit here will be
aligned by to the next query it doesn't
make updated up max so I still use the
previous proof so I don't update to the
previous proof and because the next it's
not updated by the alignment strategy
this random bit will still be 1 and
finally I will see a new max in d1 so in
this case I will switch to the shadow
execution and for the current query I
will use alignment of two because of the
alignment strategy arm on the first
execution d2
so finally what we construct it's the
exactly the same as what if you look
ahead so it's the exactly the same
alignment as I showed you before in the
alignment strategy too but this doesn't
require any Locker here semantics or in
the in the programming semantics or in
the programming logics so so the change
in this new system called the shadow DP
is basically we've tracked two versions
to execution two extra executions on the
trader Jason database and both of them
are described by Odie so intuitively the
shadow DP extends light DP by tracking
three executions at at the same time you
might think well that might make it much
more complicated for the programmer to
verify the code but we also did a lot of
work to simplify the implementation it
to simplify the design so at the end of
day the programmer actually still only
need to write down very simple
annotation in the source code even those
type system underneath tracks three acts
executions at at the same time so this
is only annotation required for the from
the programmer for each sampling command
we require the programmer to write down
which execution do you want to pick so
you want the shadow execution or you
want to align the execution and what
will be the alignment for the fresh
noise you get so that's the only
annotation and it's a sake of time I
would only explain this very carefully
but this is exactly the alignment
strategy I showed you previously in the
in the example so you can specify where
when to switch between the shadow
execution and the normal execution and
how much you want to align the new fresh
variable the fresh randomness you get
from the sampling man wrap up this new
work so in terms of soundness we still
have a son in sphere and saying that a
verify the program is satisfied
differential privacy compared with light
DP this is strictly more expressive not
than IDP and because light DP can be
thought of as
version where the shadow copy is never
used the usefulness we do not sacrifice
usefulness due to the improved
expressiveness the only annotation
required is on those sampling
instructions and finally we can still
the rest of the procedure is the same as
lie DP so we can still reuse those
off-the-shelf program verification tools
so this is some evaluation results we
have on a couple of differentially
private evidence and how much time we
spend on type checking and how much time
we spend on verifying the target program
we have a prototype which is open source
and it's we're still making it more
useful for average programmer the
message here is that it's very quick to
type-check to the source code and it's
also very quick to verify those target
programs to finish the last step in the
form of verification
in summary what both of the light EP and
shadow DP system guarantee so the core
is a relational dependent a type system
so the type system actually Deacon holds
the differential privacy some property
on distributions into some sub tasks on
non-deterministic programs which make it
much simpler to verify it in a formal
way due to the lack of time I will not
describe another work happening at Penn
State so the the idea is that what it
it's great if you can verify this code
but what if the code is wrong it's buggy
in the first place zero will be ideal to
find some common examples from the
differential II believe the
differentially private are we done and I
show that it's actually not
differentially private so we proposed a
statistical method of finding current
examples when the algorithm violates our
differential privacy and if you are
interested on both tandem I will be very
glad to talk about more details and
answer your questions and this is a
paper which contains more details about
this statistical method so that's the
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah sure so this it's a little bit like
fast if you know what the fuss is the
difference is in fast you track the
sensitivity meaning that the upper bound
on the difference so a fast distance one
means that the difference between two
related executions the difference is
upper bounded by one in our system we
are doing this alignment proof so what
we need is the exact difference between
two values to finish this proof the
injectivity that's that's the answer for
that question
remember I forgot my question by now I
can take it offline oh is verifying oh
so dinners are the better question is
why does it stop at one shadow execution
like one could imagine yeah like if
you're running many sparse vectors sort
of in parallel with the same loop three
is always enough that's a good question
so the question is why one shadow
execution why not multiple options for
the proof right I think there's a
fundamental trade-off between the
expressive power and the usefulness so
what we find is this is a nice sweet
spot so we can prove use for evidence
without making the type system quasi
complicated usually you don't need I
would think in term of backtracking so
that you need just to you committed but
then you want to change your mind that's
where you go back and do restart in some
sense so you don't need a really
exploring I cannot see an example
okay
[Applause]